thank you everyone for coming I'd like
to talk about our deep learning
processors Andy said so yeah I'm one
thing I should mention dis petaa scale
what I mean by that is we do mean a
petaflop but these are going to be 8-bit
and 16-bit deep learning flops so not I
Triple E double precision flops so if
any of you are from the HPC community
and don't get too excited there huh it's
not I Triple E but yeah so just a quick
gauge how many if you're familiar with
deep learning yeah yeah all right so
just oh one thing before I start on our
name used to be in Gemini LLC does our
legal name but now with Y Combinator
were changing to about this so just to
clear up any confusion there so I've
just slide basically for the sake of
completeness basically deep learning
workloads as you know have require huge
amounts of data to be shuffled for
pretty long distances and to do once in
a while you do have to compute on them
so basically that's kind of the workload
were trying to accelerate I have an
image of a continent up there of course
we l STM's and our n NS are also pretty
common so yeah and of course in this day
and age if you want to build a chip then
it better be for and it's a specialized
chip so not a general-purpose processor
then it better be for a worth workload
worth accelerating and so rather than
bore you with a bunch of bullet points I
just thought I'd show this the chart
which is a little bit outdated as you
can see but I think gets to a general
point across so deep learning is a worth
workload worth accelerating percentage
and error rate yeah error rate on image
net man things have improved as well and
so from 15 so when we first started this
company basically we wanted to provide
really an order of magnitude over well
over well two orders of magnitude over
GPUs but also kind of order of magnitude
on what's the best you could do if you
were kind of optimizing for compute and
so what we had is a pretty ambitious
target I guess you could say is we
wanted to cram a petaflop and again
these are 8-bit
sixteen-bit flops into a TDP and
something similar to de volta and around
300 watts right so and other thing about
this is we didn't just want to say oh we
have a petaflop of available performance
you could get on some magical workload
that it's like an unicorn right no we
wanted to get a petaflop that you can
actually see in real life on real world
networks and so just for example there I
have that is a hyperlink to accelerate
that benchmark de volta on LST NS and
they saw that it wasn't nearly as good
as what advert advertised hundred-twenty
teraflops was and the primary reason for
that really is you simply can't feed
those computing units fast enough and
really the primary reason for this if
you think about what the state of DRAM
memory systems are right now is write
write something like I've been with
memory tied minute with - I think yeah
so - with us on something order of
several hundred gigabytes and if you
just cram a petaflop under you won't be
able to feed the thing enough and so
can't we just wait until Moore's law
saves us right so this kind of
questioned its well for any proof pretty
much any previous special-purpose
processor excluding perhaps a couple of
niche applications it just basically
been Moore's law that's kind of wiped
everything in way preventing general
operating a special purpose entrance
from making ahead headway into it and
really to answer ties not really because
this is a point of some contention like
whether or not Moore's law itself has
actually slowed down you know but more
importantly regardless of whether or not
you think Moore's law itself has
actually failed is that this is a very
nice thing called Dennard scaling for
those of you who don't know Dennard
scaling is basically you know it is a
rough approximation it's that we have
doubled the number of transistors but
they're approximately half the power
consumption due to the reduction in the
nominal VDD and as a result we're able
to in the same power consumption get
double number of transistors and
everything's dandy and that really
hasn't been true from like the 40
nanometer indefinitely from 28 nanometer
node and this one is actually from
Nvidia that points that out so and just
to give it an example of what we what we
didn't want in any petascale
duplieren
processor we made this is again not to I
should note that this is an April Fool's
joke that Adam type it out so I'm not
trying to denigrate add up to have a
great company but basically you know
there's like it it's no use if all it is
is a completely fixed purpose matrix
multiplier with no on-chip memory and it
consumes like a kilowatt of power right
it's not really super useful so that's
what we really don't want one to make
when we're talking about a petascale
deep-learning processor so in order to
reach our goal someone ambitious goal
then we need to be pretty much ten times
better than what our current batch of
offerings are and the question I
immediately get is how on earth is that
possible right these are supposed to be
processors already optimized for deep
learning how can you be even hope to get
ten times better than what they're
getting and basically the question is
start where there's three doors - right
so right now compute for a most part for
deep learning operations as measured in
something under order of femtojoules
but the cost of doing access to memory
let's say high bandwidth memory it's
going to be an order of pika jewel so
like if you see something floating
around like okay we have several peda
ops of performance then you quickly find
out that you need some hundreds of
kilowatts to feed that thing with memory
which isn't really isn't really feasible
so so again basically what's the
obstacle to our little deep learning
supercomputer on a chip right and if
you're from the semiconductor industry
you know that has a completely different
connotation there but basically the
problem is really data movement as I say
um so the problem that I run into a loft
of time when I try to bring this up is
that people say okay well what if we
just in some isolated cases we can put
all our memory on die doesn't does that
not solve our problem and answer that is
really no because yes you solve one
serious component which is two off trip
memory access but what you don't solve
is two on chip data movement problem and
that's characterized by gonna be the RC
quadratic problem right two
interconnects and this is the problems I
can think coming more into focus as
exascale kind of grapples with these
issues and hence the timely source
they're from horse Simon at Lawrence
Berkeley National Laboratories and
really the issue that he points out is a
look it costs us even more to move data
on chip than it does to do an operate
upon it so this is a really a problem
that needs to be tackled that at least
for most part isn't being addressed
right now so criteria reiterate the same
point that really this ten to twenty
percent of the problem is kind of into
focus here right so we've seen companies
and a lot of literature as well say okay
well we can do away with floating point
we can stick there just fixed point
operations and that biases some power
buys a some performance even but really
you're you're missing the eighty nine
percent to eighty ninety percent of the
problem which is eighty nine percent
problem which is the data movement cost
and a memory cost and as you can see of
course LST M is gonna require more but
chances are as the models progress and
progress through time they're going to
get more complicated require even more
memory and that's going to become a
serious well it is already a balton life
but going to continue to strangle the
system right and so the source for this
is from DARPA which itself is actually
from a source here at Stanford so much
much slower than yours if your memories
you know you could optimize this but
it'll just move you I mean it seems like
you're even much worse by language I
know right so I was a different problem
but like when I talk about data movement
here I maybe I should've clarified I
meant more data movement for the
activations rights and so they're gonna
be very large activation tensors and
weight memory so they move it in that
way yeah yeah in Toronto yeah I'm a
sorry maybe should have I mean there are
other ways to deal with Iowa as well
right but yeah it is a problem so yeah
this slide is pretty sparse so for us no
one no one solution is really going to
tackle the entire entirety of the
problem so we really need to take a tax
problem along multiple angles so we do
it at the architectural level and
circuit and device level as you can see
up there so let's dive into the
architecture it's a is again optimized
to it's optimized to reduce data
movement right as I said and so to give
you some concrete numbers on that
on average this on 28 nanometer by the
ways so we're basically getting the
average interconnect length of 50
microns so if you're if you have some
idea of what CMOS interconnect modeling
looks like for the most part this has
been the resistance negligible regime
and for a most part at least on 20 an
animator for us we can get away with not
having a repeater so this is a big
advantage in terms of power obviously
those repeaters also leak like crazy but
in terms of the data movement problem it
does reduce it reduce the cost of that
data Muse been quite significantly just
at the architectural level it is a
dataflow architecture and it's dataflow
architectures are kind of well I guess
they've been thrown by the wayside a
little bit because in a way the ideal
workloads Furnham hasn't really been
found deep learning pretty much is in
many ways the ideal workload for it
since the primary form of deep learning
I guess primary form of expression for
deep learning is a computational graph
right tensorflow grasp I torch both my
torches dynamic but attentive de what
you're really modeling is a
computational graph and that map's
really well to dataflow architectures
and if you're familiar with the
literature on adult on a kind of East
source of neural network processors is
that there's a lot of data reuse
optimizations that are possible
particularly for convolution which is
that you bring the data in from some
memory bank you can actually reuse and
do some work on it when more work on it
before you have to put it back when you
bring it back in again and so as a
result you can save a significant amount
of power and everything obviously and so
there's been a couple of examples in
literature the iris iris isn't one that
comes to mind from MIT
although basically we're a decent bit
ahead of literature as of the moment
right now so this is important because
for the majority of workloads probably
most people aren't going to be running
some really exotic network so for the
majority of workloads you're going to
see a pretty good speed up on that which
is important to getting to our goal we
have what we call it a tensor native
memory architecture so a little bit of a
buzzword in a way but basically what
this essentially means is that instead
of having something like a scratch pad
memory or something you basically have
something where you address large
contiguous regions of memory
and it's a tensor and it does slices of
the tensor and so a slice of that large
continuous sector and this is useful
because in deep learning you're very
rarely going to access like let's say
one specific point randomly so as a
result by making by setting up the
memory structure in this way you're able
to get more bandwidth and from it you're
able to and be able to lower power as
well and allows you to set up this is
more a circuit level thing that allows
you to set up some pretty nice bit line
capacitance production which is in
pretty much any modern memory array as a
significant source of the power
consumption and one final thing is that
we pipeline to expose parallelism so
GPUs nowadays right so the way you get
throughput and performance is to load up
256 or so images at the same time
running through in parallel and that's
how you get throughput oh we don't do
that we basically didn't have the entire
thing as a giant pipeline that's and
that way is you go through - of course
you couldn't expose some really nice
parallelism and a big kicker for us is
that one
DLE ardeal these are core equivalent
basically it's a deep learning element
it has all the memory it needs so not
only is there no memory required off die
but there is also no memory required
outside of the local region which is
about 500 microns by 500 microns outside
the one Deeley so that saves on ship
date and movement quite significantly
yeah so here is kind of just a
high-level overview of what we're
looking at
we just have 9d Elise I want to show a
gds - here but we're thinking of
changing foundries so wasn't able to do
that plus it's kind of hard to see what
all the wires in the way but just I have
nine of them for illustration purposes
here just know for petascale trip
obviously nine won't fly you're gonna
need something like 2400 of them and in
terms of al used our friends at about
200k al use so basically as you can see
they're just a little more in this but
we haven't finished filing on that so
but basically in general what we want is
one deal these should approximately map
to one layer this is something pretty
nice so you take a resonant lay it out
pretty easy for to lay out for any
further software side of things so to
give you an idea of about how big these
steelies are and how I guess performant
each one is
obviously it's possible that some layers
are going to be much bigger and in this
case you can several dealies can
basically work together and the most
common way to do this is going to be
that one dle basically operates by
taking all the memory from the other
dailies because most more likely than
that the layers are not going to fit
into one dle by because it doesn't have
enough memory and since the memory is
the the most at least it's close to at
least around 80 to 90 percent of to die
of each dle so it's probably going to
take the memory from neighboring dailies
and so the wit interconnection works is
also very as you can see it's pretty
simple it's a grid layout with one with
one exception which is what these things
which we call flyover networks which are
basically as they sound they allow
instead of having neighbor nearest
neighbor connections they allow
connections to kind of further dailies
and a reason why that's useful is
because we're starting to add decent
called skip connections pretty common to
pretty common nowadays but basically the
general idea is that normal well normal
well previously like something like Alex
net would just have layer 1 feeds into
layer 2 fees into layer 3 and so forth
so very nice and simple
DLE mapping but now we have res nets
which maybe have one to four layer one
to four has a connection and you know
that that's possible in a grid layout
but also more inefficient so these
flyover networks basically allow for
faster communication there and we
there's a level 1 and level 2 right now
I just have one for illustration
purposes and this is useful because the
layer 1 basically interconnects 3
dailies so in a row and in a column and
level 2 network interconnects the entire
row of them so that's for more general
purpose programmability it's slower of
course but allows for more
general-purpose programming and there's
no real okay there's no major
instruction decoders like you're
probably used to like you have some
amount of instruction memory and you
have some dynamic instruction decoder
and you can program it that way instead
it's programs like C GRA would be so
like a coarse grained reconfigurable
array it's similar to that's kind of an
analogy in a way so basically you
statically reconfigure it and if you're
using something on dynamic graph stand
we have the mechanism
or that as well basically you lay out
how it could be how all the
possibilities the graph could take and
then you decide dynamically where it to
go so kind of like tensorflow fold if
you're familiar with that mapped onto
hardware an entire trip is asynchronous
so these so these aisle interfaces
basically their job is to make the chip
look synchronous from to the outside
world but internally it's asynchronous
so this input basically receives its
input at the clock signals and and then
basically that part is much simpler it
simply is the clock is simply seen as a
synchronous validation token and on the
outsider is a little bit more work for
the output interface which basically has
to take basically has to ready - I'm
ready the a synchronous and asynchronous
basically amount of data being flowed
through and turning that into some sort
of clocked at the outside world is going
to see and these each have small buffers
associated with them as well yeah yeah
yeah it's a distributive dealing so
probably means you you have to fuse them
so that would be done statically so you
take one step where you load all the
memory yeah and then you yeah so there
would be one step reconfigure basically
how the memory is going to be used so
for example if I were to do something
like a convolutional net I don't have a
huge I have to unroll that outside and
then load it in you know how it's you do
like say a three by three you have sure
horse take the image then you have to
I'm rolling into a night at nine folds
inner image right you mean for the in
Toccoa implementations yeah I mean I
don't know is there a better
implementation yeah we basically do the
spatial convolution directly but the way
it works is basically arm so yeah so in
the if the input interfaces will like I
guess this kind of store the entirety
left up input as much as you want until
it goes into DL you spit maybe we're not
answering their question yeah yeah and
here's kind of general block diagram
it's kind of coarse-grained but gives
you a general idea of what it looks like
yeah
do you have questions oh okay yeah so we
did say that we have circuit level
improvements so I guess an
underappreciated source of data movement
and I put that in quotes because when
you think of data movement you usually
think shuffling large activation tensors
or large weight matrices but there's
also on clock lines which do transmit
some form of information so in a way
kind of data movement but not exactly so
basically the reason why this is
important now it or actually has been
historically as well as because as
consumes a significant amount of power
and there's other issues with it as well
that as maybe a consumer you don't care
too much about but the designer has to
deal with a clock skew jitter and all
these issues which are really irritating
but so historically the solution to this
has been something called asynchronous
logic which is this somewhat bold notion
of let's say let's get rid of the clock
and basically put the onus on the
circuit elements to perform data
validity checks but basically the
problem is it historically there's
something like a 2x or greater overhead
like if you look at for example null
convention logic you're pretty much
going to have a dual real implementation
where you essentially end up doubling
the number of rails for every boolean
value you would have and you'd have to
have possibly more depending on your
implementation you might need hysteresis
holdback and other additional
transistors as well and the problem is
it's it's not really super feasible to
put that a into a commercial product and
B to make that necessarily super
performance such that it doesn't impact
your area too much and so our
implemented and this is at the 4-bit ALU
level for a full cost of implementation
is 10% so if you've been into any of the
async conferences you'll know that
that's probably quite a leap from what
you're used to saying and I do need to
mention it's a full custom design so
it's that doesn't mean that we can
synthesize any arbitrary circuit into
that but for the purposes of our deep
learning chip it's adequate and getting
very high performance so yeah and of
course you get all the additional
performance and other guarantees of
async if you can satisfy the QDI
requirements and you're probably
depending on well we use qvi but if you
can satisfy those QDI requirements then
you get the functionality immune to
process variations
much higher performance
we have about a 12 gigahertz clock and I
of course gave her some clock run quotes
because that's just an average number of
oscillations per second I instead and
this is on 20 again so yeah and to give
an example this is our simulated data at
0.7 bdd so basically these 4-bit ALU is
our pipeline to make full max and you
can see well below 80 second delay and
interesting thing about this these clock
rates so to speak is that the memory
access is actually much closer to being
done within one cycle as long as the
pipeline can be warmed up and so what we
do is this really cool thing where we
actually use the dynamic logic in cents
amps so we're actually able to utilize
this to pipeline the memory and almost
access to memory and what one
oscillation cycle would look at look
like and so this is something somewhat
similar to if you look at CPUs for
example they might be running at 4
gigahertz but that's only going to be
available if you're selling it into
registers but for the most part of your
l1 data cache for example might require
something like 4 or 5 cycles to access
and of course more cycles more deeper
you go into IRP the worse it is so we're
actually able to a pipeline I get
something pretty close to running at
what are the logic elements are running
out which is pretty important to
maintaining good performance so just to
give some data on in some pretty
waveforms I just add unready signal
which is pretty much critical to all
asynchronous implementations I have to
put almost because there's some exotic
ones like a fan junction out there so
compared this is compared to standard
cell implementation again on 28
nanometer depending on the voltage it's
going to vary depending on the voltage
is going to vary so we're we aim to run
around a nominal VDD of 0.7 volts so
that we get some very nice advantages
are much faster and much lower power
than a standard cellular implementation
huh in a waveform think the green yeah
the green ones isn't the red is standard
Sofia
yeah so uh I did mention that getting
moving data off diets extremely
expensive so basically the question is
if how can we fix that right so the
immediate solution as well let's just
put everything on to the diet
unfortunately for the majority of use
cases this isn't really super feasible
you can only get so much memory with the
60s for himself
so the solution our solution is well
let's get get rid of 60s for himself and
so new memories holds new memory
technologies in general kind of have a
troubled past
so for us we have to have a couple of
requirement which is that if we if in
order for it to work especially being a
start-up we need to have a company which
is we can't have any new materials -
absolutely critical and we can't even
have any process modifications so this
includes the new litho steps or anything
of that variety so we were actually able
to get that and we call a zero change to
the process itself after a zero change
silicon photonics which means basically
we're able to use a standard process and
get this memory cell on there but
basically we're I should mention one
thing we do need one one feature which
is generally considered an RF feature
but is on 28 16 7 and we've caught up to
TSMC Samsung Global Foundries and they
have no no plans to deprecate that
feature so far but for the sake of
completion I do need to include that we
need that feature for the cell to
function and so it's not something
exotic like am i I'm capacitor but it is
necessary but the results are quite nice
so we're able to get 5 times denser than
the standard 60s Ram if we enable
multilevel approximately 10 times denser
and then again the standard 60s for him
and of course the big advantage here is
in leakage SRAM leakage for all the IQ
dominates a large portion especially
when you have a lot of memory probably
dominates a leakage of the chip so it's
very important that we reduce leakage
per bit there and as far as yeah in
terms of the metal stack requirement
this new test room and also how does
that affect routing dusty so there's
nothing in there's nothing in the metal
stocks that diseases this is purely at
the transistor in substrate level
yeah
or how many for the actual wiring just
for a single bit cell
how many ml layers are using a DA would
depend on the implementation you could
you can use to start yeah yeah for the
the standard lines yeah yeah and so of
course the question is does this thing
actually exist will it work and well
we're pretty certain in confident to the
will we've done some tea CAD simulations
they're pretty promising for getting
multi-level operations so fingers
crossed for that and next month we've
got a shuttle going out so yeah so 3
sucking so this is another way we're
able to reduce data movement which is
let's get more memory onto the onto the
chip right
so one way to do is 3d stocking number
of problems with current with the
current ways we do 3d stocking wide
isn't necessarily super popular one of
them is without a doubt through silicon
via TSP has a lot of disadvantages he
had a ski lodge keep out zones and
requirement for electrostatic discharge
protection could go on and on parasitic
capacitances etc but point is something
better is really desired so this is kind
of our wireless link as you can see very
good numbers um compared to what the TSV
would look like out of 40 gigabits per
second is to demonstrate the total the
total bandwidth that you can push
through each link doesn't necessarily
mean that will I use 30s or something to
actually push this but just that's what
the link itself is capable of and it
does it only uses the metal layers so
the it doesn't it doesn't go through it
and it's wireless after all so basically
that's really advantageous since you can
actually do work under there you have
memory under there and it's release
'full and because of that again we don't
need electrostatic discharge protection
which is really nice as it saves a
significant amount of power especially
when you compare something like a TSV
there is some crosstalk right now we're
just dealing with that by spacing them
far apart which deals with the issue to
drive bandwidth higher you can use
techniques like multiplexing and thing
so yeah I have a pretty waveform there
as you can see probably won't see this
beautiful way from in silicon but based
on the comparisons we've gone 2 tsps and
doctor coils it
seems to be doing pretty well and again
these are all on 20 an animator on this
as you can see a Fanta joules per bit
that's pretty much as cheap as going if
maybe like 150 micron stage over on
diets on to dye itself so you save a
significant amount of power simply by
just having the memory 3d integrated on
there yeah yeah so we have a comparison
so this is just a show to maximum
achievable bandwidth per square
millimeter
so the TSV is you don't get very much on
foreign gigabits per second pretty high
power consumption for a bit there's one
big problem with that coefficient though
is that there's no logic at all so the
entire region of theis basically useless
in doctor clothes do much better about
double the bandwidth similar amount of
power now you can drive dot lower that
power lower or the bandwidth higher
that's going to increase coil area or
decrease or increase power consumption
if you want to drive to abandon with
higher so I chose this to the optimal
trade-off it's possible to get to stun
to ten Fanta joules per bit but at the
cost of approximately quadrupling the
area of that so that is there something
but they do get logic underneath it
should we're able to drive up to tenter
bits per second through these links per
square millimeter at a significantly
reduced power consumption again we also
get logic underneath it and we can drive
the bandwidth even higher with
multiplexing we don't really have plans
to do that right now but it's a
possibility
if yeah analog feature yeah all the
shooting on your red curve glitch before
the transition what's that about the
simulation of that code because the
inductive coupling or orange
undershooting machine of the red
curve like real has a two bit slower
yeah I did not investigate no normally
have that overshoot at the end of it
yeah anyway maybe after diagram reverse
the digital signal processing scope
okay I think it's a digital signal
processor in fact that's how we can yeah
we can talk more about well do you have
this radiation pattern that sets your
desk your wireless connection yeah one
of things though it's wireless yes yeah
we can talk more about that okay but
yeah hope your secrets so you know
because you're not using yeah yep but it
seems to me but you have a coupling you
know whether it's going wirelessly or
with a wire there still I don't see how
I can go down by I guess maybe I don't
understand why it goes down oil because
it's still coupled even though it's
wireless right so okay there's a couple
of reasons why first of all tsps has a
very high sorts atticus constants are
very large the other reason is TSA you
need electrostatic discharge protection
which adds a decent amount to it I mean
again it's it doesn't we're not the only
one we're not the only ones that has
power consumption this law I as I said
through chip it's possible with
inductive coupling to get your power
consumption down to around 10 fentanyl's
I think for a bit but AD that's at the
cost of signaling increased area the
other big problem the other big problem
with 3d stocking has been basically the
heat problem right so if you have 2
Dyson and your total TDP or something
like in the range of 300 watts it's not
gonna it's not going to be very
thermally feasible to stock these two
dice on top of each other and so
basically that for the majority of high
performance applications just as kind of
help to really limit just straight 3d
integration I mean 2.5 D is still
feasible a straight 3d not so much and
so basically the goal is so we need to
find some way to deal with the thermal
problems the gigantic issue especially
if we're talking about something like
Volta TDP dice so so here are some
here's some not our as you can see
obviously not ours but some thermal
analysis models that we
and disclose hours here for some reason
for good reasons but we'll eventually
obviously but as you can see the general
point still stands there basically these
compute regions and of course the center
of Todai have these hotspots and
basically we need to find so there's an
observation basically and we need to
find some way to deal with it and other
observation is that these hotspots also
especially appear around compute region
for the most part sans computer or on
average going to have higher thermal
thermal density than the memory regions
the memory regions may have they may
comprise more power power consumption
overall in the entire die but on a per
per per capita basis I guess they have a
higher compute region to have a higher
thermal density yeah so there's a couple
of ways we had actually attacked a
thermal wall on this is one of them the
other ones we haven't finished patents
on so excuse me for that but basically
the idea is that well let's take a it's
basically exploit what we've learned
from thermal analyses and it's kind of
obviously applied so what do we get well
the first thing we get is well memory
regions are cooler than compute regions
at least per at least in terms of
density so let's not put them on top of
each other let's only put memory regions
on top of each other and leave compute
regions exposed we also this thing
called thermal multiplexing which is
basically and not acts not dynamically
activate regions of to die that are kind
of directly on top of each other since
that means basically on the low thermal
resistance paths that are available here
are already going to be saturated and of
course more heat in one region not a
good thing if you're familiar with the
literature on power multiplexing this is
somewhat similar in the sense that we're
doing it in three dimensions instead of
two dimensions and we're doing it at
doing it on a more I guess on a finer
grained basis rather than on upper core
basis so for example these ones are
probably going to be our region's off
the memory rate that are activated so
this is so the first one is what we
don't want second to is in through time
basically how we access them so we might
dynamically activate these regions and
these regions and we can schedule this
out because the deep learning workload
is deterministic enough
yeah yeah before operations begin we're
going to schedule how these are going to
be activated so right but I mean in
general you're not going to be able to
dynamically activate call if you're
dying in any case right at maximum yeah
I mean this can be done on a very
fine-grained basis like so like yeah my
plan just know whatever excess talker is
talk right you know they basically
activate everything all the time well
right right so but well for one this
thing generally happens in memory since
it's primarily memory gets going to be
stocked so it's easier to do that there
I mean they well in a way like at least
they occupy most of her compute regions
when it's pipelined but there's
definitely still Riyad at least for most
matrices and most more close there's
going to be periods of time where parts
of it aren't activated right like you're
very rarely going to get full
utilization if you look at the TPU v1
paper which I presume you're referring
to on they only get like really good
utilization on like one or two workloads
for the majority of four networks are
only getting something like I don't
remember the exact numbers but one of us
as low as 11 percent so maybe all our
memory sometimes it's not a problem
yeah so yeah that's what we're doing
here anyway so this wouldn't be really
confusing so what would you see as a
like guests of activity factor or the
logic portion of the chip so for our
chip or yeah um probably in the 50
percentage range that I would give you a
delivery of petaflop okay yes yeah and
that's the equivalent of your switching
activity yes researching activity and
though into logic only yeah oh so this
scheduling is done by the compiler ahead
of time yeah so I did promise in my
abstract comparison to some other up to
deep learning chips before I start I
just want to make it very clear I don't
mean this is an attack on anyone and I
want to just say that when I really I
guess
getting going on about these external
memories the reason it's not necessarily
a bad design choice given the current
technology to use off trip memory and a
high bandwidth memory formats so just
keep that and bear that in mind
ah so let's start here first of all
they've publicly stated that alder
memory is off die and immediately as you
can see it's going to be a little bit of
a problem to bring all your memory in
off diets
simply want to be infeasible right so
dot right there pretty much is going to
be the and if that a graph core for one
at least they do huh get the idea right
you want to reduce data movement and you
want to increase memory bandwidth since
these are the real bottlenecks in
performance but unfortunately they all
have a couple of issues first of all
this all to all interconnect which is
necessitated on both dice which is
necessitated by their ah which
necessitated by basically their
synchronization scheme they call it bulk
synchronous parallel but basically these
things are going to be serious
bottlenecks especially as you scale it
onwards like the I guess if you general
think was at the back end of the line is
not so glamorous as the front end of the
line but to interconnect delay in the
back end if the line is really
delimitation limited limiting factors
here and as you can see if you have this
which is going to be long wires it's
going to dominate and eventually if you
keep scaling this as you get more
transistors but not necessarily
improvement interconnects it's gonna
start to strangle the design and of
course there is also these um chip to
chip links they only have 300 megabytes
on die so that 600 megabytes total but
only six and remember it's on die on
each die so in order to go to the next
site you need to go through these I
presume use of service links and those
are going to be under loom realm of at
least 10 people joules per byte
depending on what you use so those are
going to be very expensive as well so
it's a really close to 300 megabytes on
die and even then 600 megabytes you know
depending on what memory are not memory
whatever data sets you're using on it is
probably not going to be enough and
depending on what model you're running
as well there I mean no 1080p images are
quite a big bitter bigger than the image
net images sizes that we use so we're
able to get our memory on chip to about
128 an ohmmeter to about
half gigabytes so this is pretty much
close enough to fit most of the models
that you're running today pretty nicely
compact neon dye and on 7 and the other
FinFET process that are much smaller
were able to get much more memory into 6
to 8 gigabyte range and of course we
have about five times as much overall
peak performance that we see there
anyone have a question yeah 600 square
millimeter and with the 3d information
yeah wait now six hours for a millimeter
on on top of that we have to read an to
briefing on it okay so on just the logic
die or earth so that one half is full
dies yeah yeah this is just to give an
example what it could be but I mean for
in okay little dip it depends on what
arm we can drive does higher actually we
have plans but that we have plans to
drive that higher you know they pull off
the memory wall yeah three times earlier
well okay well I'll I'll it in terms of
data set eyelid like so say the data
side that's a different story but in
terms of memory just in general memory
aisle where you probably will reach that
sure it'll be layer but my point is for
like probably let's say nine percent of
workloads this will be enough and we
have plans to drive this higher as well
that we you know haven't been able to
publicly reveal yet so so compared to oh
this trip actually more information
became available out just this morning
so the general point still stands going
to off chip memories might be very
expensive about hundred twenty times
more expensive instead of two forty
times the other thing is basically each
they have about 30 megabytes of total
memory on-die information as of this
morning they have and they're pretty
much they're relying upon the software
manage memory on high bandwidth memory
and to manage that interspersed answers
across memory so I'm going to that's
approximately what they said in the
release so I'm going to assume that to
me and they say they're relying heavily
upon their
been with memory too due to heavy
lifting and that's going to be extremely
energy intensive to do another
interesting thing is DS about just large
memories in general not necessarily
specific to Nirvana but the physical
interfaces for high bandwidth memory if
you've looked at let's say die shots of
a really large GPU like a Fiji or
something you'll notice that the HBM
physical interface is actually quite
large so even going through that will
inish it will incur some level of data
movement cost on-die of course nothing
compared to how much this is going to
cost but just something keep in mind
I'll compare it to the TPU so TPU v1 I'm
probably a little bit rushed which
explains a couple of decisions
ITB v2 may be a bit of a better
comparison but just - nonetheless to
give an example here basically they have
this unified memory which is really kind
of throw some off to a large extent
they're only able to get about 24
megabytes onto there which is enough for
some cases but still not still not going
to be ideal and plusted by having such a
large single memory raid being
monolithic I feel me that's how their
actual implementation is it's going to
be very expensive in terms of just in
general accessing that thing data
movement on the die itself just even
inside a memory array and basically the
in you can probably incur some pretty
gigantic capacitances on two-bit lines
if you have such a large memory array
and the other thing is there the
bandwidth to and from their from their
memory render matrix multiply and just
in general they're computing it's is
very low we're able to get around and
we're from a hundred to and I think a
thousand times yeah a thousand times
that in aggregate bandwidth so a
significant greater there and basically
the two costs they really suffer from
are from going to be on chip data
movement and on the first generation to
ended up accessing drm as well so that's
gonna be an enormous ly expensive but
again the TPU b2 doesn't use that so
maybe a better comparison should be
there yeah yeah so again it's a better
comparison probably to TPU v2 so again
the problem here is really the high
bandwidth memory I'm going off diet just
going to be too expensive to really
be useful day out fixed systole stay
Seder systolic erase systolic array
matrix multiplier units so these things
really don't have any program ability so
I mean that's could be a disadvantage if
you're Google scale you probably can
make another chip if something else
becomes common but it's just something
important to keep in mind would be would
be that and of course this seems to be a
largely monolithic design as well on
here with some advantages since I split
into two at least there and I also get
asked a lot what about like analog
approaches right have you considered
analog approaches and so well yes we
have actually we did a little side
incursion on that a couple years ago but
basically there were some we found some
serious problems with analog approaches
in general so even for deep learning as
it turns out that deep learning can't
tolerate like zeros are like really low
precision
it does have some precision Browns it's
more tolerant to lower precision than
let's say a HPC workload but for the
most part it's still going to have some
level of intolerance to low precision so
as far as I've seen in literature
there's been no evidence of that there's
been at least one common I think mythic
that said that they can retain accuracy
okay I'll give them that but Miss Lee
the current approach is first of all our
flash memory-based this is a bit of a
big problem because there are the
endurance issue and this is for top of
declined SLC nor flash by the ways so
this is an Intendant more for iot sort
of applications I presume not really for
high performance applications where
you're continuously just running data
the other thing is it requires very
intense power intensive area intensive
and also very hard to scale are the 80
the 80 season backs right so those are
going to be a serious issue as well the
flash memory itself if you've seen a
Ganta or just even casually looked at a
flash memory scaling conference you'll
see that scaling of a floating gate
transistor is extremely difficult to do
and so that could possibly be an issue
right and the final thing is it really
doesn't so much salsa date a movement
problem and the reason for that is
because so you in one processing element
are not pressing on one memory array you
can do process
let's say right analog computation but
now if you want to move that to another
let's say region of to die which you'll
need to no matter how dense it is then
you're still going to need to transmit
it over some sort of lines and the
problem in interconnect lines here is
that if you seen just current sensing
current sensing by the ways has been
proposed as an alternative to current
interconnection schemes to increase the
speed and but if you look at it it looks
a lot like a damped harmonic oscillator
that degres extremely quickly so it's
pretty much impossible to retain a good
analog signal going over those lines and
you're going to need to add some sort of
compensation like and most likely this
is going to mean you're turning into
digital signal which you're back to
square one in terms of data movement
there yeah and I mean so there's
difficulties with that as well and so
finally we get to the part where okay
this is great I don't care how good if a
processor you have how to actually use
it right maybe I'm a deep learning deep
learning guy how to actually use this
thing right so this is really nice
because the deep learning community us
and all deferments have started to
settle around this abstraction for
intermediate representations called the
computational graph and most real Ness
is Facebook Microsoft and Amazon have
gone in on this project which they call
Onix and I think i pronouncing that
correctly at least and basically does a
lot of - a lot of - work for us which is
basically tensorflow towards whatever
cafe whatever framework you want to use
it emits some sort of computational
graph intermediate representation for
example Onix has already been integrated
I think with PI torch and and tensorflow
is a work in progress I think and import
so basically we would intercept this and
we have our little graph compiler which
isn't so much a compiler plus a little
bit of a misnomer since it's relatively
simple to lay it out on to the actual
hardware but we call the compiler sure
DNN see see it's our nickname for it
after GCC but the real takeaway point
here is that for you as the user don't
see anything right so you write your
tensorflow code you go tomorrow and it
runs exactly the same as it except
you'll note yeah
leadership weight from this high level
yeah condition is busy it's it's I mean
okay well compared to like something if
we were trying to I would say poor LLVM
canoe trip okay yeah I mean ithi will be
relative amigas compared to the yeah I
suppose relative but I mean come yeah
compared to something like what like
suppose us reporting LLVM to like a need
to company architecture that would be
pretty difficult right why I'm not a
compiler guy yeah you don't yeah you
don't see many of the mechanisms we have
to make it easier for it but I'm busily
rehab on Midgley the action more depth I
guess more at bar like will mean up to
detail levels is that is a lot not a lot
but least a little bit differ from what
you see like it's not clocked but it's
done in such a way that the compiler
sees some some types of guarantees on it
so it's easier for it's easier for it to
schedule yeah there's a lot of stuff
dating we're able to review arcing talk
more automatic so basic most general
solution as long as it works for let's
say 99% of the cases we are happy yes
and like that last personification it's
gonna run really slow but it's well you
know this like first shows where that's
going to be the majority of applications
yeah yeah yeah so the custom layer
basically becomes a little bit more
difficult you but you have to implement
it as some sort of some representation
of functions we're also from just
operations I mean on in computational
graph so let's say your simple example
would be like let's say I want implement
dilate the confluence right so then I
would on represent it as some sort of
nesting out let's say addition and
convolution functions in the
computational graph and then we simply
take that in compile is just this normal
the the issue arises when you start to
use things like if you have a call to
library or something then you have to
and then that's when things get hairy
but
I said that's when we - that's when the
compliation becomes difficult - but for
cases like that it's going to slow down
other chips quite a decent bit as well
but yeah so if we're basically again for
this is antenna probably 99% of more
flow this is going to be a perfect fit
yeah so working on basically confidence
Ellis teams are n ends the various
application special transformer networks
all sorts of things they're really the
only thing that's being it yeah yeah I'm
fully connected of course that's the
basis but I really it only becomes
difficult when you have so different
amounts of control flow really that's
when difficulty arises yeah you can
write your own but here again here's
think the biggest thing here is that
control flow basically slows it down so
I mean as a general heuristic control
for slows it down yeah hi there's a
little bit more but again it depends on
how much but yeah it's really hard to
estimate also depends on what it is
right like if you have something similar
like simple like what a rally would be
that may not be at all slow down but if
it's something really complicated then
like a very long switch or something
that could slow yeah um so basically
we'll do it for both but um our first
chip for business reasons has to be an
inference chip but we intend to
architecture to do both yeah then I mean
this is that's intended for a data
center type we can cut that die up -
yeah this was very interesting but are
you familiar with the similar system
developed by Professor Jack Dennis at
MIT perchance I suspect you're not the
data flow he he started pushing that
fifty five years ago without much
success
yeah that's what but it's similar enough
that since I opposed all patents I will
tip him off to try to blow a hole in
yours
in terms of purple oz levels like what
what do you see a difference between
your matrix multiplication level 3 vs
level 1 level 2 no data on that yet I'm
not gonna speculate well this isn't
intended to be like a like a this isn't
intended to be like a kind of HPC trip
or Isis and we've been our benchmarking
more like BG like we're close like well
not in features you so much but rather
than that stuff like that how do you see
the performance difference between your
sort of Alex net CNN versus you know now
it's TM what sort of performance
drop-off yeah okay well this is entirely
independent how large LST M is like any
model size estimate million activations
million activations probably should you
cease you see something no drop-off at
all so so each one of your en n units
contains one activation or no so so on
our dealies yeah yeah for dealies have
large obviously there with their
activation weight and memory is sector
so basically its sector changeable so
they like there's I think there's six
sectors we're going for it now yeah so
basically the dos sectors contain some
amount of memory which can be
reconfigured to be on all six four
member mates only or all six four
activations and anything in between so
dot so basically the point is that it
would be reconfigured approximately to
how much activations you would have but
it's definitely not one it's a lot more
I mean we only have like 2400 of these
on a pretty large die right so you'd
have fit several activations onto one
right yeah yeah versus in matrix
multiplication where when you're
multiplying two matrices a and B and
you're repeatedly accessing element a
matrix a or each multiplication there
would be a drop off in your case versus
the scenario where you're not having
that kind of cash friendly nature right
right so this is again works it's not
necessarily intended to be for general
purpose because if you write something
look and let me answer Patrick so for
generally the way we have Alice name
implemented right now is also like up on
our side but it's implemented a little
bit more in a hardwired way so dead
that's not so much of an issue I'm right
now but if you go write something let's
say that's kind of looks similar to an
LST M but isn't kind of is doesn't have
let's say preset preset hardware to be
able to assist it you'll see a drop off
there sure what is like the kind of a
deep form of your layers is a matrix
vector product rather than a matrix
matrix product yes because you know
existing architectures with their
caching systems are so good at matrix
multiplication that that's what they're
you know the problems reformed into
level three blahs one rather than level
two and so if you're doing it a level
two to form that reduces the amount of
work you actually need to do I mean yeah
but again okay well this is kind of
bringing back to the date for the most
part we see our performance drop off not
necessarily when to compute requirements
are different but when des memory
systems are different for the most part
we don't see computing impacting the
compute probably generally doesn't
impact is it that much in terms of how
much it is it's going to be more
impactful when the memory when let's say
we have way more memory in one layer and
way less on other then it's we see
memory being the primary difference in
terms of how much performance we compute
you're still doing most each other that
I get ride together
it's multiply add its that yeah you're
just executing different yes yeah yeah I
got what you mean by Mike yeah thanks a
question are these really matrices are
rank one outer products amazed Darrell
well you nested from called a rank one
alright the Google times finally
admitted that tenses are I please rank
to make our ch'yeah
the sum of two our products yeah it just
like books yeah it's so is that the same
thing here yeah because then you should
use tensor flow misses all I mean it is
not tensile nobody perplexes I will what
I will okay I will agree that there's aa
Arizona said and we use the word tensor
a little bit too much in deep learning
but I mean no totally
that ain't no tenths of a business bank
wanna make to matrix and it is not
attention that's how you're gonna matrix
actually other comments by precision or
more efficient I'm not the one who named
okay if it was me I wouldn't have named
but yeah yeah so yeah of course someone
is that I don't yeah yeah exactly
I mean tensor sounds better than matrix
I suspect that's why Google yeah so yeah
time I'm basically okay when can I yeah
so one can I actually get one of course
as I said the MPW is going to validate
what I suppose could be a call that more
it's risky technologies to three
stocking in the memory cell everything
else will be if things go to plan we
hope to get some engineering samples
shipping to some early early partners
and eventually get a 28 something
shipping on 28 and eventually all the
way to the 780 meter FinFET eventually
that will be a mask owned yeah I think
that's about it
you